i want to talk about uh cultural issue
before we go to super chat so we have
one more segment this is from podcast
movement yeah heavens they've apologized
to ben shapiro saying as we stated we're
continuing to evaluate our policies
guiding social media and events with
inclusivity diversity and respect for
all we have to start by sincerely
apologizing to mr shapiro for our
reaction when he visited a booth we sold
his company that wasn't right just think
about how insane that is yes we'll sell
you a booth you show up to said booth we
condemn you showing up even though you
paid us and we knew you were coming to
me so i can respect them now for coming
out and uh saying the right thing and
apologizing to ben they say it began in
2014 when four podcasters had an idea to
create a community blah blah we're now
looking to move forward as we focus on
the original mission from 2014 being a
hub for podcasting events okay you know
you know what look i respect it
you know always give respect what
respect is due they said it was wrong
they're apologizing to ben shapiro fine
daily wire why don't you just create a
podcasting convention they probably are
already working on it yeah
jeremy's podcasts stop giving money to
people who hate you do another
commercial and then we'll get a booth
there too that'll be great we'll do a
podcast there
yeah but don't call it podcast because
that's an apple thing the ipod you know
zero
just a show but it's like a broadcast
specific a broadcast maybe yeah yeah
that was really weird i know what you're
saying but i also don't have the right
word because podcast has become so
specific in our vernacular broadcast
comes from when they used to cast seeds
when they would plant a field they'd
cast broadly and they called it a
broadcast and then it just kept in the
vernacular until all of a sudden now so
we could retake broadcast isn't it weird
if you think about it though like the
the the launch of podcast people had
ipods and then someone was like i'm
gonna make a talk show to put on your
ipod and then like all of a sudden
people were listening to these things
it's just something that apple's like
we're gonna get their minds but then
when like spotify was like we want those
two they had to keep calling them
podcasts they should stop but dude like
again what's the alternative shows this
is called a vodcast yeah video video on
demand cast
that's right yeah podcast so we uh
forget apple
are you a podcast too
yeah i'm a vodcast wow yeah i don't i
don't call it that i call it a podcast
yeah but so like rogan's is called the
vodcast this is a vodcast
video vlog like a video vod means video
on demand
so
it's like it's not a podcast like
podcast was on ipods and now these talk
shows are video on demand podcast dude
that's it that's what it's called yeah
these are vodkas now
but that's well they're also shows i
like show because it's one syllable the
show could be like a theater like i'm
almost thinking it's too nonspecific to
be like come to our show convention like
are you putting on theater performances
are we going to the movies talk show
talk show
but if you're talking about someone who
doesn't know and then what do you do i
have to podcast you wouldn't say vodcast
right they'll understand it yeah
i guess
coming up with a new word i like do you
think we could definitely come up yeah i
don't like google is a verb either i
don't like that these corporations are
in people's minds i don't do that
anymore i don't
search it yeah they say bing it
duck duck go in that's right search it
on google if you want so the point the
reason i brought this story up was not
to debate words in semantics but to
point out another culture culture war
victory and they named it they said
bench peers specifically by name i think
that's that's the master shapiro it
could have been very easy to be like
we're sorry if any of our actions upset
someone no one in particular though you
know there's a guy why they did this
like why did they apologize you know
there's two there's two ben shapiro's in
media there's probably more to be honest
but uh the editor i think the editor of
vice magazine his name is ben shapiro
literally ben shapiro yeah and when i
worked at vice ben shapiro
and then he was like at the time this
was back when ben only had maybe like 20
000 followers or something and so it was
funny because people would mix up the
two ben shapiros i don't know what he
does now though but you know clearly one
benchmark
benjamin shapiro yes i'm pretty sure he
does yeah yeah i wonder if they're other
you lost your name like imagine that
imagine like that's it your name is like
john smith or whatever you know let's
say let's say your name is you know i
don't know something more
weird ian crossland yeah yeah
and like imagine
like when you're coming on the show ian
there's another dude who's like got a
master's degree in like he's like a
master a chem he's got he's got a phd
let's say phd he's actually doing
graphene research experiments and he's
going around talking about how much he
wants graphene and then everyone's like
oh you're that graphene ian crossland
guy and he's like
yeah i am from that podcast that hippie
weirdo no no i'm the phd sorry you lost
your name someone else is now more
famous than you with the same name so
but they're then contacting you and
being like tell us about your experience
in your doctorate program and you're
like what no that person wouldn't exist
and that other guy is to go by like ian
jamin crosslands now
should we get rid of names and just use
numbers then
yeah that works
yes be a lot of them i see 74316. what
is your opinion on graphene i was going
to change my name to ian like prince or
cher i was about to man i was going
through a midlife crisis i didn't do it
anyway my point is i guess what i was
trying to get to why do you think
they're they're they're back pedaling
yeah i don't know it just seems like
they're under digress or something it
feels like the right is getting cultural
pressure
and companies are now realizing it's not
worth it did you see what christopher
tweeted about disney
registered voters disapproving of disney
now they're underwater i guess
like no no their approval rating among
voters is 51 percent
among independents it's 47 among
republicans it's like in the 20s or
something
so disney is surprising to me actually
not me
like have you have you seen the latest
stuff they've been producing i have them
i'm always surprised at how much people
are paying attention i guess
yeah but i kind of feel like
it's it's watching disney is the the
definition of not paying attention you
know what i mean yeah if you're trying
to watch
marvel
and then they they show you she-hulk
twerking or something you're gonna be
like okay hold on a minute
like i'm not okay with whatever it is
they're doing yeah and then all of a
sudden you're political mm-hmm jennifer
lawrence wants everyone to be political
well she's afraid of tucker carlson
she's having she's having time and
probably right now she's having a
nightmare about tucker girl said poor
girl oh so strange but here's what i
said with her they said they said she
had nightmares starring tucker carlson
it's like for all we know her nightmare
was like aliens are abducting her oh and
he saved her tucker has got like an iron
man suit and he saves her
probably disturbs her
does that mean that she watches him
regularly for him to show up in her
subconscious yes
that's what that's true like i would
never have a dream about chris hayes
because i've never watched a show right
right what if she's like hate watching
them every night yeah they say like
sometimes people that you see on the
street or like you interact with in a
restaurant will come will be in
subconscious because your mind remembers
their face right but she's seeing tiger
carlson so frequently she can identify
him in her dreams like
that's i think actually telling us like
what's going on at home
they're not like they're not nightmares
they're they're actually amazing i
imagine
she's not you know you have a nightmare
you know you wake up in a cold sweat no
no she's having
beautiful
fantasy dreams where she's on the right
on the back of a stallion and tucker
like you know he's like they they trot
up to like a beautiful waterfall with a
rainbow and birds of paradise and then
she goes oh hold me tucker and then he's
like you're so beautiful and then she
wakes up just like normally with her
eyes slowly opening goes okay that was a
nightmare
that's it yeah she's actually having
deep fantasies i'm supposed to not like
that right okay then it was a nightmare
not a beautiful experience a beautiful
experience
she's only calling it a nightmare
because she won't tell people she's
dreaming of tucker carlson she does well
she's got to go on
like she just told us that he's taken
out in herself
i learned from the best in media thank
you brian stelter headline jennifer
lawrence has recurring dreams
about tucker cross and or about jennifer
lawrence constantly is constantly
dreaming about being with tucker carlson
boom there we go yep
i wonder if she's in the dreams with him
i got to know more i want to know about
i want to know everything about these
dreams just tell me i want i want the
whole it would actually be funny if the
dreams were like she walks into an
office building and tucker's a
receptionist and he's like just fill out
this form sign here and go to the third
floor and then she's like ah like what
if it's the most banal and mundane
experience she's like in bed and her
husband is like secretly watching tucker
carlson while she's asleep and that's
what it is he's like hearing her voice
and so she's like seeing him in her
dreams but actually like it's her
husband's like i'm a closet conservative
when i when i would go to sleep watching
adult swim
i would have scooby-doo dreams all the
time and i was like constantly in the
mystery machine you know with with
scooby and it was it was funny because
like scooby and shaggy would be saying
things and then in my dream i'm like
responding to them but they weren't
talking back and it was the weirdest
experience and then i would slowly wake
up and scooby-doo's on you know that's
that's probably it that's it that's a
chapter it's her husband he's he's a
huge joker carlson fan
she's like yeah we're going to bed no
problem like you you lay down she's
having she's i mean she's like having a
dream where she's like driving in her
car and tucker sitting next to her going
and now the democrats want to want to
steal it you know it's like i agree it
might be feel very strange to suddenly
have tucker crawls and like lecturing at
you in your dreams but especially if you
think you don't watch him but you
secretly do liberties are very weird she
said that she became a liberal from
watching 30 rock yeah i did see that one
but but she said lemonade because it was
a republican well i yeah i don't know
which part of 30 rock made her a liberal
i don't think it makes any sense at all
she was like i watched it when i was
like 13 and you want to be like you're
super grounded in your political
opinions yeah
liz lemon in 30 rock goes into i can't
remember whose office and she says that
she tells her friends she voted for
obama but she secretly voted for mccain
that's funny she was a secret mccain
voter maybe that's what she's trying to
tell us you can be a democrat outwardly
but you can hide it you can actually
vote from the second yeah like like
secret trump supporters that's what she
but the crazy thing is that's why she
watches her but hold on like what kind
of person voted for john mccain it's
interesting because
a large portion of the current younger
trump supporters are not fans of john
mccain at all yeah like warhawk
warmonger but liz lemon did and she's
liberal
she's further right than most of the
trump supporters to be honest i don't
know what a weird way to become liberal
i watched a show
where i was 13. yeah
i became an anarchist because i watched
how you met your mother you're like what
what does that make any sense who said
that oh i'm just making it up right
that's one way to become an anarchist
yeah i realized that life was pointless
yeah
i became uh uh a nihilist from watching
big bang theory
because i realized people actually like
this stuff oh my gosh big bang theory is
so not funny it is the least funny show
i have ever watched in my life have you
ever have you ever seen it when they do
um they take out the laughter
oh oh my god so comfortable
and it's like what happens is like dude
walks in and then he's like what are you
doing and the guy goes i'm working on my
thesis and he goes just like a fibonacci
sequence
oh so uncomfortable and then they just
that's it and then you're like
what
but like there's i remember watching one
where he's like that's my favorite
fibonacci number and then there's like a
laugh track and i'm like where's the
joke yeah dude i don't i mean
it's off the air now okay
yeah is it
i think so i think so it was like a big
it was like but it was like i mean
people like the show
i think i don't think people think they
feel smart because it's like some
science words in there and so they're
like oh yeah science hey look i think 30
rock was fantastic i like dirty rock
yeah
my husband and i both like that are you
now a democrat because of liz levin i'm
that's why i came on the show to tell
you
i am i am coming out as a liberal
because of liz lemon yeah cool there we
go thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there